yeah i think that all of us expressing
what we were here
to express is i mean makes it worth
being here
you know and if it's not if we're not
expressing who we are
then it's this it's still a play
it's still a presentation but it's it's
not um
it's just not so fun to be here if i'm
if i'm my ladder is leaned on
a different house you know it's like if
it's leaning in the in the direction
that
has me be able to show up and serve and
be expressed
and feel
then i'm then i'm in and i actually
think the sensation
in our bodies of inquiry and going
within i think that also counters
patriarchy because patriarchy is so
out of body yes very it's very head at
best
yeah um i love being in the head but um
but it has its role yeah i mean it's
like a like a filter or a sieve or
something you know
you know what i really wanted to do i
don't know i would probably it's just
gonna take too much time and i'll have
like 7 000 questions for everyone
but i wanted to go through your albums
and be like what was the sort of
catalyst and lesson with each of them
but i don't know if we'll have let's
just go with the last one
let's just go with such pretty forks in
the road um so
why because you know you don't write
albums like on a
yearly basis or every other year it it
takes a while before i get my music from
you
i'm going to look at that i'm going to
really look at that no no it's all right
on time and it all is coming from
such an again organic place which i
think is why you've stood the test of
time and why
it you have such dedicated devotee fans
like myself
because it's authentic and you can't
rush that right
yeah and so it's just got to be natural
and flow so
what brought this one on this one was
postpartum
i started it in malibu with onyx and
i mean i think of the song losing the
plot
and diagnosis as me just going okay so i
feel really pathologized i feel
you know everything about postpartum
unless someone's experienced it it's a
tough one to explain i mean depression
and anxiety is it's just become more
ubiquitous now so
people have a general sense of what you
mean when you say depressed or anxious
postpartum in general have whole other
elements to it
of these invasive thoughts and
they're terrifying you know so it's um i
wanted to write
i needed to write to to tell the truth
about the about my experience
um after having given birth to onyx my
daughter and
and then i kept going and there was the
disillusionment with okay i'm not a 21
year old in hollywood anymore what does
that mean
why am i here um am i you know the am i
gonna
try and look 21 for the rest of my life
probably not
i mean clearly not um and
yeah these songs were some of them were
retrospective so some of them were about
traumas sexual abuse healing traumas and
then
some of it was my relationship with los
angeles some of it was
um a real identity crisis of like you
know
spiritually i know that a lot of times a
spiritual turning point for people is
is like you said earlier when you're
kind of alchemically ground
into something challenging although i've
learned a lot of things without with
ease as well so
i want to give a moment to the to the
idea that we can learn things not just
through hardship too
fair totally fair um
but yeah is there any song on there that
you want me to talk about more
specifically or just
the whole record basically just yeah i
just think because i feel like there's
got to be an impetus
on some level and there's something
to to put you into the creative state
and that's what i'm curious about yeah
what
what starts it actually it's it's just a
little voice
the voice goes it's time
and then i go okay it's time to write a
record and then i figure out what studio
we're going to use and who who i want to
write it with
i love writing alone but i live to
collaborate so
mike farrell and i worked on this record
together and
i called it the piano record the whole
time because it was just us alone in a
room
with a piano and a mic so and then we
flushed it out with alex hope and
catherine marks both direct um
directing it i call it directing i
really think the music business would
benefit from that word because
sometimes producer producer makes sense
but i guess executive producer is what
they call director anyway
um well yeah it just there's a turning
point where all
it's physical like it's time to write
and if i don't write i'm gonna get sick
if i don't express myself i'm gonna get
really depressed
so it's exciting and daunting when that
turning point comes
if all were equal i would love to put a
record out every two
every two years but now it's exciting
this new climate it's exciting and
daunting
is the idea of just kind of ongoingly
putting out music i remember
20 years ago i was like why don't why
don't we just put out a song whenever
you feel like it and
people are like oh lannis it doesn't
work like that
it doesn't work like decades and decades
of doing it like this it's just fine
don't
don't upset any apple cart yeah and then
um but now there it is so the pro
of it having been sort of one note
before was it would be touring
falling down and recovering and then
writing another record again and
rallying again and touring so it's just
this cycle
and there were times where i could in
theory be under the rock and hide under
there and
generate stuff under there whereas now
it's constant so it's not every four
years i'm doing something it's there's a
new song coming out next week there's
there's there's new songs and one-offs
for lack of a better term
um that are happening now so it's it's
constant
expression and constant generative
and all these other areas like animated
shows and you know there's
you know speaking of speaking of mania
the ideas don't stop basically so my
whiteboard is full
and then i have an incredible team
around me of people who are willing to
work with me or collaborate with me some
things like the musical
taking eight or nine years you know and
other things
taking an afternoon and recording it you
know so what's going on with the musical
um the musical
is coming back post pandemic i don't
know exactly the date but it'll come
back to broadway and then they're
opening
in sydney they're opening a jagged
little pill musical too
that's so cool yeah i have to ask maybe
like my one of my favorites
or like old school and i just have so
many memories um
because i was in england at the very
beginning of my stint there
and the album had just come out and i
remember that's not like all i played
but when supposed former infatuation
junkie came out i was like
oh my gosh that one seems so much it's
so
deep i'm curious what the impetus for
that was
it's like did you go to india and have
an experience and meet some gurus
and like i'm just so curious because
yeah and or just like
i just to me it's like such a deep album
thank you no i
that one was really daunting to write
because a lot of people
were wanting me in some way whether they
knew it or not they were asking me to
repeat jagged little pill like make part
two right
um and also wherever i went grocery
stores anywhere the
the only question that was being posed
to me is when's your next record when's
your next record
and the more i heard that the more i
kind of
wound tight to be honest and i remember
going to toronto to visit my friend tim
thorney and
my intention was to start to write
supposed
and the studio was set up beautiful
candles it was idyllic
and i turned to my friend tim and i said
i don't want to do this
i don't want to write i don't want to be
here and he was the first person who
said
okay well then let's not write let's go
see a movie you know we went to a movie
we had a sandwich
and then when we got back of course i
started writing because i just felt like
i had the freedom to write or not write
and you know i i thank my friend tim all
the time for
for just providing that space and
freedom to not write
you know so i had come back from india
and i had gone there to just sort of
step away from everything and
just be a brown-haired girl from ottawa
canada again
you know and
yeah i don't know if india itself i mean
it's to me it's a
it's one giant altar you know everywhere
it just smells like an altar everything
is prayerful there
and in bali in certain places and
probably egypt where you just were too
there's a sense of soulfulness and
spirit
that i wish we could sort of trickle
around the whole planet sometimes
but um but when i came back from that i
remember feeling
liberated somehow just somehow
the idea of going to india and letting
go
allowed me to just think okay well what
do you want to write what do i want to
write about what
what do i care about right now and and
that's
it was almost like there was a fork in
the road at that moment am i going to
try
and attempt to repeat which i actually
don't even think i could do
i think if i tried to repeat i couldn't
do it um or am i going to just keep
seeing what comes and writing what is
happening you know and i chose the
latter and i'm so happy i did
yeah would you think that it's uh
because i agree
the idea that it would be possible to
just do another jagged little pill album
is
is um you know might not even be
possible
is there something you think that you
left behind with that album personally
that because it's like
when we change the things we see change
right so like how could you can't really
you can't be that atlantis anymore
so what was it that changed from that
point
the turning point was to the degree that
ego was involved
and service it shifted
because my ego scratched that itch and
grabbed the brass ring and swallowed it
you know zeitgeist wise and you know
you know breaking records and all kinds
of
really heady sort of egoic things um
and then i just thought well why would i
keep going because a lot of this is not
actually really enjoyable for me my
temperament um
but i could see that people in the
audience people coming to the shows were
being given permission in a way
permission to be human you know so i
thought well that's
i mean if someone were to ask me what on
my deathbed like
what was the most important thing is
just to be able to
offer love in macrocosmic ways and then
tiny microcosmic
intimate ways you know so i could see
that through my career and through
expressing myself that everything i
valued was being
imbued into all of it whatever i wrote
whatever i performed how i moved it was
all informed by this
this idea of just wanting to show up you
know and and be of service and
and leave the room a little cleaner than
how you found it
that's a great gift do you feel that
that's your
purpose or what do you feel your purpose
is
just i think we're all unique filters
and we all have these quirky
intelligences and and abilities
and if we can hone in on who we are
to that degree what our talents are what
our capacities are then we can
work with those you know and then this
filter is
is contributing that it's kind of like
another another way of saying what you
said earlier which is that we're gonna
if we know who we are in terms of our
talents and our
intelligences then we can show up and
use them and then life's a little bit
more jumping out of bed in the morning
versus the daunting
you know no matter where we are even if
we kind of hate our job is there a way
for us to
to show up from this place of service
you know that just makes it all worth it
to me because otherwise
i don't think i'd i mean being in the
public eye is coolish
um but i don't think i'd want to just
stay in the public eye randomly for no
reason
and i think what's happened in the 70s
and 60s certainly ego was everywhere but
a lot of people were
you know wanting to be expressed and
that was part of what their fame
story was but now it's like fame in and
of itself seems to be some kind of end
like fame is the check mark and i'm like
oh god it's just so
it's so hollow it's so lonely you know
um
and i think it exacerbates anything that
was going on before fame so
if there were any insecurities or hyper
defensiveness or anything if that was
going on before fame
can almost be assured that it'll it'll
triple
as soon as as soon as fame comes into
the picture